from the second president Trump
announced his plans to address
birthright citizenship earlier today the
left freaked out now here's what the
president told Axios the only country in
the world where a person comes in has a
baby and the baby is essentially a
citizen of the united states for 85
years with all of those benefits it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous and it has to
end
have you talked about that with counsel
yeah I have so we're in the process it's
in the process it'll happen an executive
order now predictably open borders media
types were quick to denounce the
President and condemn his even raising
the idea of ending birthright
citizenship as if we needed it there's
more evidence that immigration remains
the president animating issue his new
proposal to end birthright citizenship
he's talking about birthright
citizenship you know - and I think he's
done that just simply to inflame the
issue I mean that this is the hardline
immigration message the fear of
immigrants changing the way of life of
Americans really harkens back to some of
the darkest chapters in America's
history when in 1857 the Dred Scott
decision well move over Encyclopedia
Britannica look this is the default
behavior of all those afflicted with
Trump derangement syndrome when they're
faced with an inconvenient truth they've
demonized the president and just dismiss
out of hand the issue heaven forbid we
actually present the American people
with a factual unbiased presentation of
the issues now first of all President
Trump had already committed to ending
birthright citizenship during the
campaign
so aside from his mentioning the
drafting of an executive order the
pathway to fulfilling this promise
hardly a news flash and why is this an
important issue in the first place for
the President and so many of his
supporters and I would dare say
Democrats as well a lot of it goes to
the money consider the number of
children born to illegals each year back
in 2010 the Center for Immigration
Studies estimated that between 300,000
and 400,000
are born to illegal aliens in the United
States annual annually
now that figure is bound to be a lot
higher today given the new research that
the number of illegals in the u.s. is at
least double what was originally thought
or about twenty two million
let's conservatively say that four
hundred thousand children are born every
year in the United States to illegal
immigrants well those are people that
hard-working US taxpayers have to
educate and for whom they provide health
care and in many cases food stamps
obviously infrastructure etc etc CIS
estimates that the annual cost to the US
taxpayers of children born to illegal
aliens is a staggering two point four
billion dollars yes think our vets and
our homeless and our inner-city schools
could use that money maybe we could even
pay down some of the debt well to burrow
down a little further a 2015 CIS report
found 51% of immigrant headed households
used at least one federal program cash
food housing or medical care compared to
only thirty percent of Native households
and we aren't just talking by the way
about folks on visa overstays or who
cross the border illegally many of you
would be stunned to know that there are
entire industries both here and abroad
that are now devoted to gaming the
birthright citizenship system called
birth tourism and it's become big
business in the United States attracting
immigrants from China Taiwan Mexico
Russia and Turkey what they do is they
purchase package deals where they can
come to the US as a visitor for a few
months or several months and have their
baby on American soil for upwards of
50,000 dollars these foreigners are
guaranteed US citizenship for their
children it's wild and that furnishes
them of course with preferential College
treatment when the kids reach age 18 and
they also can sponsor their parents
for green cards on their 21st birthday
that's pretty nifty now I'm sure this is
what our founders intended when they
were drafting the 14th Amendment right
now contrary to what Obama and so many
in the left are saying today President
Trump by questioning this birthright
citizenship
you know mantra is provoking a
conversation that I think is sorely
needed in the country so rather than
just castigating the President or
caricature in his position why not have
a substantive debate on it how we want
to proceed with immigration in the
United States seems like a worthy
conversation to me to have especially
during the midterm election and up until
now Trump is the only president who's
been willing to have that debate what
are the Democrats afraid of here and
that's the angle